we both have in common working at sign
out live i worked there long before you
uh but i am i just love
and people always push me for this but
people always ask me
what was the sketch that went terribly
wrong when you were there oh was there
ever a sketch at snl that went so
terribly
yes there is because people don't get to
see they don't get to see these
so i was uh one of the first movies i
worked on was movie called purple
violets it was directed by ed burns
and he is a very nice guy but i was
listening to him talk all day
and i would go back to the office and i
would try to do i would do ed burns
you know and i would watch his movies so
it'd be like you know his movies are all
kind of like yeah
you know the girl i like you know
instead of a cop she wants to be a
firefighter
and uh and so we
had written this sketch when paul rudd
had hosted
right and it was a sketch where i was uh
it was called ed burns grill boys
and it was us grilling
now they didn't okay so
and and we were like
and when i and then i we went out there
to do it addressing i
did the voice but paul for some reason
would not do the voice
and i don't understand why paul decided
not to do it
how dare you
oh dear you see why didn't you do that i
could do the voice
i did the voice
well what happened what did you know you
you disagree that this
memory is very hazy yeah
now i might not be a trained monkey boy
like uh your man over here with the
voices
but if i remember correctly
i did do the voice the reason this
sketch didn't work
is that it was terrible
we were standing around both of us as ed
burns
just talking about our pop and grilling
meat
[Laughter]
and it was hilarious we thought it was
funny
but it was it was it was a construct it
was an idea that just did not fly
yeah in fact this is true
lorne said in the in his
history with the show it was the
worst
received sketch that's fantastic all the
time yeah
we did it at dress and it didn't get one
not one laugh
not one
[Laughter]
thankfully thankfully they actually do
film the dress rehearsals they do if you
would
[Applause]
and you will see what i'm talking about
play the sketch
[Applause]
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
so you can see why it bombed
i didn't think whoever dies first you
have to do that in the other ones
yeah oh you know what i can't believe
how many years has it been it's been
like 25 years of you coming on the show
and you would never show you you'd
always say i've got a clip and you would
every time for years i would be
convinced that i would see the real clip
because you're such
a genuinely nice person and you would
say you know this movie's really
important to me and i i put my idea
really well
i put my money my own money into this
and i really care about this
and then you pull that every time
i never really imagined 20 years ago
yeah
that here we would be yeah well someone
obviously on the internet
put together they didn't even do all of
them no but you can see
i mean you don't age but you see me
you see me go from like a hairspray to
like
you know just rotting pumpkinhead and
you see it happen over a period of years
and it's absolutely
stunning it's this crazy performance art
that lasts forever
i just remember the very first time
thinking it's so artificial to come on
and
sell your wares and show a clip from
your movie and what if i just show a
clip from another movie right
right we've never talked about this
really but um but
uh i thought what if i show a clip from
this movie that i saw a long time ago
that is just really strange and there's
one scene in particular but i was
i was kind of uh waffling because there
was another movie
that i was obsessed with at the time
that
was equally like who was this made for
yeah uh
called baby geniuses baby geniuses does
anyone know baby oh okay
bob clark yeah yeah right that's right
you were so there was actually a
contender there was a content there was
and there was this idea there was this
basically there was this scene i
remember
a baby they're breeding these super
babies or something and
one of them escapes and these i don't
know like
seven or eight grown men chase after
them and then the baby jumps out
and just beats the out of all of
these
grown-ups and there are uh there's this
kind of
demonic laugh that just keeps recycling
over and over again and it's
clearly a little person and just beating
up these uh
but it was it was so bizarre and i'd
always
the whole time i would almost go with
that then i almost did i never did i
never showed obviously i just stuck with
this but
i always was thinking about this clip
and i thought seeing it
is your last week congratulations bye
thank you thank you thank you thank you
there was there was no way that i would
not come and i i was wondering if it was
all right we could show
i could show you the other clip that i
was talking about yeah definitely yeah
[Applause]
horrible man hey love you foul
bill header
look for barry season three bill hader
pro run i love these guys